the new royal couple is already on the
job this morning just days after
revealing their engagement Prince Harry
and his American fiancee Megan Markel
just arrived in the English city of
Nottingham they are visiting a charity
fair to mark World AIDS Day Jonathan not
Jonathan Vigliotti is in knotting him is
what I'm trying to say we're crowds
lined up very early this morning
Jonathan everybody wants to see them
good morning good morning a lot of
excitement and today really marks a
royal rite of passage for Megan Marco
while she's no stranger to walking down
red carpets as an actress
today she walked into history just as
then Lady Diana did in 1981 and Kate
Middleton in 2011 megan merkel made her
first official engagement with Prince
Harry by her side
Marco may have left her fans in the US
but she clearly has a new following here
in the UK where hundreds of people have
lined up to welcome her an eager public
watched on some waiting hours to catch a
glimpse of Prince Harry and his American
fiance you've been here since the crack
of dawn why was it important for you to
show up this morning she used to give
our support to Harry and Megan Merkel's
visit to the World AIDS Day charity fair
in Nottingham marks a quick roll change
from television actress to House of
Windsor when she appeared to handle with
studied comfort royal photographer Chris
Jackson has spent more than 10 years
covering Prince Harry and now his
wife-to-be that gonna be you know a
formidable team and I think and we've
got a lot to look forward
Markel discussed her own royal ambitions
earlier this week I think in these
beginning few months and now being boots
on the ground in the UK I'm excited to
just really get to know more about the
different communities here smaller
organisations we're working on the same
causes that I've always been passionate
about today's carefully chosen public
debut was a symbolic nod to Harry's
mother Princess Diana who championed
hiv/aids awareness up until her death 20
years ago images of her shaking the
hands of patients without wearing gloves
helped change the way the world
understood the epidemic what do you
think your mother would have
Megan or said about Megan is there
because there's Prince Harry alongside
his brother Prince William and
sister-in-law Kate have devoted much of
their lives to carrying on Princess
Diana's humanitarian legacy with merkel
by his side
harry says he is now more committed than
ever and while there has been a lot of
debate here in the UK about President
Trump visiting Megan Markel has clearly
been a welcomed US ambassador viana and
welcome news this engagement to a
country that's been stressing a lot
about Briggs it and a lot of uncertainty
is it you can say that they're a
good-looking couple so cute together
they're so easy with each other that's
why they're in love we like to say
Jonathan Vigliotti and Nottingham
England are thanks to you